[Applause]
laws for one coronavirus Afra as he
leaves intensive care for the last time
and leaves behind the greatest physical
struggle of his life the difficulties
were extreme you know when you when you
GU rack off the natural bodily function
is to try to refill the lungs with the
air that you've just put out and if you
can't do that and that's something
you've taken for granted every day of
your life it's very scary very quickly
Hilton was right to be scared is the
limited data we have on ICU shows
patients like him who go on a ventilator
in the first 24 hours have a survival
rate of no more than 32% patients who
don't like we're told Boris Johnson
survived at least
83% of the time although many end up on
a ventilator often four days or more
after sort of four days of this you do
begin to doubt whether you can go on you
know how much longer you can take it
here I am and I'm seeing the world again
through the eyes of a child and I see
how beautiful everything is how amazing
everything is and I'm just blown away by
being here
this reconstruction of a survivor's lung
shows white coronavirus is so dangerous
the green areas are where the virus is
damaged lung tissue in icy use this can
often lead to a knock-on effect as the
body's immune system over reacts
shifting the damage to other organs
you're giving fluids nutrition trying to
prevent secondary complications like new
infections pressure sore so there's a
whole package of care that needs to be
delivered to try and obviously help the
patient get over their primary condition
so in this case lung failure respiratory
failure but also to try and prevent this
domino effect of other organs being
compromised
this vast tank of liquid oxygen was
delivered today to the new Nightingale
hospital in London
patients in ICU share a desperate need
for air but also another factor about
which we know very little what you're
seeing with coffee is that of the people
who need to go to intensive care though
to get critically ill around 75% of them
are men and it's particularly true when
you look at some of the old groups over
40 that it's really predominantly men
who are affected and I think it's really
important to say that people don't yet
know why a disease that strikes aspire
our own immune system could be said to
have done the same to our political
system attacking the head of the very
government we elected to protect us not
because of who he is but because he's
Hugh Rowland uncle skynews